[Music]
I'm the one
okay gang it's been uh I I think it's
hard to say it's been a minute it's been
a minute more like 12 12 minutes since
June 29th last time we did a podcast uh
everybody was out Adam was literally out
but some of us were out and we're back
uh and the first podcast we got a
special guest for you uh someone who if
you're on social you see her talking
making her arguments and everybody in
the market saying you gotta hear what
she's got to say you got to hear what
she's got to say so finally we had a
chance to have her on the podcast the
great Lauren chin it's great to have you
on the podcast I'm so happy to be here
thank you so much for having me yes of
course it's a surreal experience thank
you so much for helping us realize that
Vinnie took uh honors French honestly we
didn't know this yeah years ago very
impressive that you were able to get
that out so we're going to talk about a
lot of current events Topics in a minute
you know you'll make the introduction of
who you are for some of the people that
maybe don't know who you are guys we got
a lot of things to talk about uh Jamie
Diamond gave a speech this last week in
an interview that some people said well
that's guy sounds presidential if you
haven't seen it we'll play it for you
even Bill Bill Ackman billionaire said
huge loss if Jamie Diamond doesn't run
for president we'll talk about Janet
yellen's um
trip to Beijing as well as what happened
with Trump when he went to UFC and the
way he shook hands with Joe Rogan a lot
of people are saying that podcast is
possibly coming up very soon we'll talk
about that ramaswani closes in on
DeSantis As Trump dominates the GOP poll
this is the hill 14 promises Trump has
made in his campaign for seconds from
CNN Maria bartiroma confronts DeSantis
in on 2024 campaign asking what happened
to your campaign and his answer and
laugh reveals a lot and then outside of
that Joe Biden uh what is the optimal
time for Biden to drop out it doesn't
matter what it is whether it's the hill
whether it's the Atlantic saying step
aside Joe Biden they want him replaced
by somebody else will talk about that
this past uh on 4th of July I don't know
what you guys were doing but in this one
house
I think it's a White House they found
some white stuff in the white house
which is kind of weird it's not a
greenhouse it's a white house so it
makes sense we're gonna find that Vinnie
maybe has some insight on what happened
with uh Hunter Biden there and then
Zuckerberg and musk are going back and
forth and I don't know if you saw what
uh Elon Musk tweeted last night which is
kind of crazy Rob just told us about it
maybe we'll show Elon Musk tweet last
night about him and Zuck Biden uh says
War would Russia must end before NATO
can consider membership with Ukraine in
an interview with your guy I know you
got some thoughts on that Fareed and
then we have the movie that came out
sound of Freedom uh but at the same time
CNN Talking Heads are now saying that
this was uh the anti-child sex
trafficking movie sounds of freedom is
created out of bogus statistics and Q
Anon Concepts you have to hear this
person on CNN talking about it and
Rolling Stone comes out trashing this
movie while supporting cuties and at the
same time time an article comes out a
couple months ago talking about Rolling
Stones editor-in-chief spiked reporting
on friend getting arrested for child
porn so whereas that's a little bit
confusing when you're doing something
anyways we have a lot of things to cover
here on stories uh but before we get
started Lauren if you don't mind taking
a moment and sharing with the audience
your background sure so I'm currently
YouTuber content creator uh blazetv host
TP USA contributor but I started gosh
what was that seven years ago maybe just
posting videos on YouTube Just
anonymously for fun I definitely didn't
want my face out there at the time
because I wanted to be able to work
um which I think I've the ship has
sailed on me having a job outside of
what I do now just because of all the
things that I've said over the years but
uh what was work so what did you do so I
was actually doing
um Human Resources
HR right one time the company were doing
HR it was for our consulting company so
it wasn't really high hiring it was more
like strategic HR human capital type of
thing which I I still find interesting
but it's obviously very different
um and especially I'm not necessarily
politically correct so when people hear
that they're like really HR it's like
not the type you're thinking of yeah I
mean I wouldn't be the type to write
anybody up but uh I'm a young woman and
I was just kind of feeling like my peers
especially were having one very very uh
specific Viewpoint radical feminism
shoved down their throats and I felt
like it just wasn't representative of
not only myself but a lot of a lot of
people out there so what's interesting
that you bring that up is that you're
saying that you were started doing these
videos uh anonymously yes and you didn't
want to be known for this this is this
actually very indicative of the the
Tweet you just did a couple days ago
about well yesterday I believe when you
were in the Bahamas basically saying
that people successful people people
have made it in their life don't want to
basically put their stuff out there
explain that by the way it's funny you
say this why why do you think people are
so scared to you know share their
opinion what do you think is causing
this fear I mean I'll give my story of A
guy by the way you should have met These
Guys these are your kind of guys but why
do you think people conservative
Christians great guys they were Persian
Jews from New York oh wow who knew how
to party right this is yeah
so why do you think people are scared
nowadays well I mean it's it's canceled
culture and it's kind of it's been done
to death the issue everyone knows it's
real now but I mean years and years ago
people were starting to realize that it
was it was a thing I mean you have your
social officer that you can be socially
ostracized if you have the wrong opinion
this is especially true if you are a
younger generation I mean your peers are
being indoctrinated almost non-stop from
I mean the education system especially
if they're going to a college media
social media so I think a lot of people
they're you know they're looking at what
happens when someone gets labeled or
racist or Sexes or whatever it is and
they're kind of weighing is it worth
kind of speaking out if it means that
I'm going to lose my friend group and I
have had friends who are I guess no
longer friends because of my beliefs is
it worth being fired or having my job
prospects I guess limited just to speak
out about these issues that I think a
lot of people are saying no not not
really I'll just I'll just keep my mouth
shut I'll just kind of go with the flow
but we see where that's gotten us over
the past few years let me ask you who
were you in high school like 10th grade
11th grade who who was Lauren Shannon
High School uh quiet I was in the math
club uh played the flute and violin so
just a happening person
so so it's fair to say you were not part
of the party animal getting hammered
actually I skipped 10th grade also that
sounds great that should give you a
little bit of an indication of what my
Social Circle was got it so were you
like a 4.3 GPA painfully Asian yes
really okay shout out to the tiger moms
that was not the first grade I skipped
either so really I also skipped nine so
how old were you when you graduated from
high school nine years old I didn't
technically graduate high high school
because I was going back and forth
through Canadian and American systems
but I finished with my bachelor's when I
was 20. so you finish with your
bachelor's when you were 20. yeah I love
I haven't bragged about high school for
so long this is specifically impressive
man yeah and you said you said earlier
nobody ever even offered you drugs like
people looked at you and they're like
nope she ain't cool enough she ain't
doing blocks nothing no no she's up so
the reason why I asked that question
from is the following reason so normally
in school you know who certain people
are and everyone's gonna find each other
the party people are going to find each
other the complainer is going to find
each other the gangsters are going to
find each other the bodybuilders are
going to find each other the athletes
are going to find each other the
Christians are going to find each other
everybody finds each other right so if
if you were who you were in high school
your friends that all of a sudden are
saying well Lauren you know you're being
a little too extreme with the stuff that
you're saying seven years ago was it a
surprise to them that your opinions were
what they were I think so because if
especially if we're talking about women
women have the tendency to be very
agreeable and I think if when you're
taking a position that's going against
the mainstream which if you are at all
Center even Center left nowadays is
considered Fringe or extreme that is an
unpopular position that is
anti-establishment and I think a lot of
women especially like the nice girls
that I was hanging out with I never
would have thought of them as extreme or
radical but I think because they are so
prone to that agreeableness as Jordan
Peterson would say it's just a lot
easier to go with it to accept it
especially when you have these activists
that are painting things like extreme
feminism or the LGBT agenda as just
being tolerant and accepting they're
going to look at anyone who speaks out
against that as extreme confrontational
bigoted you name it yeah it's it's crazy
you say that so we're in Bahamas this
last weekend we took a couple hundred
people there Vinnie one night we laughed
you made us laugh for three hours
straight I had an ab workout by the time
we were done that night well we walk out
of this restaurant and this one guy
comes he says you're the Twitter guy
another guy comes he says you're a tick
tock I'm like I'm the tick tock guy I
don't even know you know so but the
Twitter guy that I'm talking to I said
tell me why you're seen on the Twitter
guy so I see your Twitch he said you
should have me on your podcast the guy
says this to me good looking you know
Middle Eastern Jewish one of fifty
thousand dollar watch and he says you
should have me on the podcast because we
can we agree on a lot of things I'd love
to kind of tell them what's really going
so why don't you have a podcast he says
oh no no I can't have a podcast so why
can't you have a podcast he says well
you know because you know business it's
going to affect us I said you're the
problem you're the reason why America is
where it's at you are the absolute
problem and he grabs his wife wife comes
over these other two guys come over
every one of them's uh listens to you so
they know content what we're doing all
this stuff yeah he is he's a fuzzy you
know he's scared he's this he's that his
friend is now joking with them so I sat
there and I said so what are you scared
of tell me actually what you're scared
of he says well what what do I do I mean
if I do in New York I'm in New York you
know if I say anything you know we're
gonna do this and they're gonna do this
and they're gonna do that that's exactly
the issue okay the three communities
that I keep telling I had a great
conversation with Dave Smith last week
we a phenomenal call together about the
three communities the lazy and scared
Republicans are ruining America the do
your thing Libertarians are ruining
America and the tolerant Christians are
ruining America these three communities
are all generally net positives to
society they contribute to society they
don't take but they're ruining America
because they're sitting there saying I
don't want to kind of give my name
called that I'd write about just be
quiet and not say anything about it
because what if I the guy's like what my
real estate business could take a hit I
said your country could take a hit your
kids could take a hit you're worried
about the real estate business but then
again it's a real valid fear that a lot
of people are having nowadays but even a
guy asked a question on the Tweet he
says Pat I'm an executive if you go to
it go to the other tweet prior to this
because this is a different tweet go
back one guy asks a question
go go a little lower I think it's that
one right there yeah guy asked the
question go to the bottom on when the
guy asks the question right there my
response to him he says Pat I saw your
thoughts on a podcast podcast and
completely agree however it is a risk
for many of us to speak up we have
bosses who don't agree with us and bills
to pay what do you recommend to come
combat that I said I totally understand
there's risk for speaking out but
there's risk for staying silent is much
bigger however there are creative ways
for doing it if you want to click on
show more you can create a pseudo name
to write blogs a fictional character a
burner account that speaks up a
community Twitter account that uh
without revealing it you kind of like
lips up Tick Tock there are many ways to
push the envelope the only thing I
discourage you from doing is staying
silent so that's kind of what you're
talking about yeah absolutely and when I
finally did reveal my face and
eventually my name it was almost it was
freeing honestly it was you it's sort of
scary because you know all right I can't
really work a mainstream job in HR if
people at my Wiki page is calling me a
white supremacist and you know all these
Terror Terrible Things white
supremacists yeah yeah I'm a white
supremacy is very multiracial nowadays
surprisingly diverse Bunch those oh yeah
working out now apparently if you work
out too much well yeah but you know you
know what you actually Pat left out uh a
part not only were we at a dinner for
three and a half hours and we came out
that that interaction with this group
with especially with this guy was like a
10 to 15 minute situation where he not
didn't call them out I mean like an
audience it was like a town hall in the
casino and it was Pat wasn't being quiet
he was going in on him he was seeing the
light and then his friends were showing
up other people were showing up
recognizing Pat and I think calling
people out Pat was was not only like a
good thing we need more people like that
who mind you he has kids in the room he
has enough crap going on where taking
that time out in the middle of a casino
on vacation to base I mean so Pat it was
pretty loud like I think we need more of
that where it's like Hey listen you're
not doing your part you're all freaking
valid concern it's a
so one we have to understand the level
of like a guy calls from Hollywood
saying hey Pat I fully agree with what
you're doing obviously I can't talk
about it because if I do my community
I'm going to get hurt I said okay
courier-wise that's okay he says what
should I do I said do you have a few
money if you're in Hollywood I don't I
said what matters more to you is this a
bigger cause in your life than your love
for Hollywood he says that's something I
got to battle with I said I totally get
it you got to do what you got to do but
nowadays the movie sound of Freedom
which we'll talk about here in a minute
but I think you want to say something no
well I just want to give you Kudos but
also kind of give a little I don't want
to say pushback but there's a different
perspective so I fully agree with what
you're saying here about
um creating a pseudonym or even if you
don't feel comfortable putting yourself
out there there are Avenues to express
yourself no doubt I would say one of the
things I love about doing this is I get
to talk my [__] right or wrong I get to
learn I get to grow I get to express
myself that's the beauty of doing
podcasts what's interesting so as I did
a minute call shout out to the team at
my neck everything's going awesome there
I mean the the guys I'm speaking with
Garage on 300 menex by the way thank you
it's great it's amazing connect with us
on the next pbd Vincent myself we'll
sign you up Lauren but I have a call
with this guy in minute and the whole
conversation was he was like my business
has taken a 50
drop because I express myself too much
I'd like to discuss with this is the
question I'd like to discuss with you on
manect what you think I should do I said
all right we get on a call it's a half
hour call I'm not going to put his name
or anything out there I said so tell me
about your business well I'm in San
Francisco I'm in the medical field and I
work with a lot of high profile people I
mean he said some names when I say high
profile I mean very high profile like
you'll know the names and he goes you
know I'm a a right center right guy I'm
a Maga guy I'm a trump guy whatever and
he goes I in the medical field I'm
making a half a million dollars easily
and in the last year my business has
taken a 50 hit he's like and now I'm
making a quarter million dollars a year
just because the people that I surround
myself with caught wind of my political
beliefs
and they've like one two three
the names went out there it's a valid
question and I said and I was like Wow
let me process this with you and I said
let me ask you something bro do you have
any political aspirations no
do you have any interest in doing a
podcast or anything like that zero I go
then why are you pushing the envelope so
much because it's costing you a quarter
million dollars a year
because that's exactly what I'm
grappling with right now I want to say
what's on my mind
but it's literally costing me hundreds
of thousands of dollars I go but hold on
back up a second where do you live San
Francisco that's the problem are you
planning on moving your business at all
no like this is where I'm at I go then I
don't know what you want me to tell you
bro but is
voicing your opinion worth a quarter
million dollars a year only you can
answer that he goes yeah not not really
but I'm glad this is circling back I'm
glad that you brought up alternative
options that people can do yes it's sad
that if you express your thoughts and
your beliefs you could literally get
canceled or lose clients or lose jobs or
lose money but that's the risk that
we're at these days but I is it sad
though because that's where I'm at I
mean obviously I'm speaking from a
position of privilege where I get to
like you said speak my mind and I have
people who support me but if you're in
this position do you want clients who
would otherwise hate your guts if they
knew what you actually believed do you
want to work for someone who thinks that
you're this terrible person who's
destroying the country do you want
friends who are only your friends
because they actually agree with you
because there are rich clients this guy
could have in Nashville in in Florida he
doesn't have to be there and likewise if
you are someone who's wanting to do
something to contribute to I don't know
a little bit of the normalization of
politically
uncomfortable ideas we should all be
investing and spending money with people
who share our values we should stop
supporting financially people who hate
us or who are trying to trans our kids
like with Target or Bud Light because I
think what we're finding increasingly is
that for the longest time things have
only gone one way it's only people who
are against the left that are afraid to
speak out the left doesn't have that
same shame you have celebrities who will
tweet the most radically left-wing
things imaginable they're still in
movies they're still in Disney and
Marvel whatever but I mean someone like
Gina Carano says something that could
potentially be a little bit critical of
I think was covid stuff she's fired
immediately is that fair no that's not
fair so we need to start I mean
enforcing the fact that we have our own
values we're not going to be ashamed of
them we're going to support people with
like Minds if that means moving maybe
that that's what you have to do so many
people are doing that now because I
think a lot of people are just tired of
being afraid all the time
by the way it's a very valid
conversation a lot of people are having
it that's great feedback but uh you know
there's there's a couple things to be
thinking about
so one is like okay so if I'm work if
I'm living in San Francisco and I want
to stay there like this guy wants for
some reason yeah
yeah okay but but species in the street
it's quaint yeah very Queens very
romantic amazing when you're going out
with your wife and oh baby I stepped in
the water beautiful okay I guess to be
clear he's in Silicon Valley which is
what still a half hour outside
Silicon Valley I got you so so you know
so so to so to go through this he's
right it is a deeply concerning thing
but by the way that doesn't mean that's
not the reason why America is in
shambles today that also doesn't mean
that it means guys like him who are
afraid to address conversations like
this are the reason why the other side
is able to get so much agenda so the
whole concept is what are we intolerant
towards again I pray for four things
courage wisdom tolerance understanding
I'm having a hard time with the third
one right because it's me tolerance I
have a hard time Donald's right and then
you see Dave Smith it tells me about a
quote by uh uh Von mises he says can you
pull up the the tweet that I just the
Tweet right there that you had go back
to and go all the way to the top of the
Tweet not that one the other one gold
way to the top of the Tweet yeah right
there if you can uh there's a quote
right there that says uh right there
classic liberalism must be intolerant of
every sort of intolerance I I have to I
have to tell you I've been grappling
with many different words in my life you
know why are we lazy I finally realize
why people are lazy your life is boring
when we're bored we are lazy so you
don't want to have a boring life make
your life exciting by constantly having
stuff to do so these things you ask
questions of right this one here you
have to be tolerant Christians we got to
be tolerant [__] you can't be
tolerant towards intolerance if you're
going to be intolerant to me who the
hell are you two thinking I'm gonna sit
there and take it from you so so the the
concept of intolerance we must be
intolerant to intolerance even for some
of the Christian Community on the bottom
where it says your eyes are too pure to
look on evil you cannot tolerate wrong
doing why then do you tolerate the
treacherous why are you silent with the
wicked swallow up the more righteous
than themselves the whole thing is
talking about is why are you letting
these Wicked people take advantage of
weak people I'm standing in the streets
I see a person being bullied I can't do
something about it no no no I don't want
to ruin my career because what if I save
that lady and then the cop comes and
arrests me so let him be to beat the
wife up it's okay I'm just gonna mind my
own business that's a coward in in a way
right I don't think tolerance is a
virtue at all actually it is certainly
not a Christian virtue if you look at
the New Testament you don't really see
Christ saying it's okay I'm just going
to accept this no he speaks his mind he
makes a very clear delineation between
right and wrong god of the Old Testament
certainly not one for tolerance so the
idea that this is a virtue something we
should strive toward I I disagree and
it's the same thing with blanket
Concepts like diversity we're supposed
to believe tolerance is inherently good
diversity is inherently good just
because but no they've provided no more
moral framework as to why those things
should be something we strive for we're
supposed to just accept it without
question yeah no I agree with that well
actually nailed it because think about
it the left the other side does not give
a damn they're not they don't give and
nothing happens to them so Pat and I'm
and I've always said this it's time for
us to be like you know what enough is
enough open your mouth if you have to
punch people in the face I mean they're
doing it what do we guess what we're
supposed to just sit back and just and
take it I have one thing to say about
that so here's here's a part is it fair
to say there's certain people in America
that they're gonna vote Democrat even if
your argument makes sense they're never
going 100
is it fair to say there's certain people
in America they're going to vote
Republican no matter what you can't say
anything to them 100 okay so the the
truth is right for both sides okay so
who are we really trying to talk to that
becomes a question the independence if
you're trying to talk to the undecided
the independent the libertarian the
green whatever the community that's in
the middle of the 12 percent you have to
figure out how to communicate with them
so if this guy's talking about this I
know a lot of people that will come and
say well let me tell you something you
know skill residential yeah you're not
converting anybody the ability to
communicate a message as well to
somebody who's saying I never thought
about it thought about that before you
can do it simply by questioning you can
do it simply by saying you know what
John I don't know if public school was
like this when you and I went to public
was it like this before I just don't
remember being like this the other day
my kid went to school and they did this
what do you think about it that is a
very open you know you're not bashing
anybody to start a conversation and the
other person can say yeah you know what
my wife was saying the same thing the
same thing happened with us the other
day you know kids going to school I
thought that was kind of weird I'm a
Democrat I'm like why'd I do that it's a
little bit concerning I'm starting to
hear this and those are the words hey
don't you think it's kind of weird like
look I don't mind taking a vaccine I've
taken a ton of vaccines but don't you
think it's a little bit weird that you
know they want pro-choice to do whatever
I want to do with my body which fine
that's a interesting argument I get that
as a person that wants to do whatever
they want to do with their body but
isn't it kind of weird that they want to
be pro-choice there but they want to be
Pro Force when it comes down to the
vaccine it's a little weird ain't it
it's a way you open up the conversation
at workplace instead of just saying
these morons these [__] as well
done that's that's also not going to
work so a part of your friend that you
spoke to on the neck could also be the
delivery of the message the delivery of
the message is just as important
um if not even more important than the
point you're trying to make you may be
right
but your delivery is so bad that you
push the person away from whatever
argument you're trying to make to them
there's a lot of people
on social media and I'll push back on
your uh what you just said a little bit
on one of the points it's easy for us to
just go hang out with each other where
we agree with each other it's very safe
to do that you ain't doing nothing
special you're not doing what these
great leaders did in the past we're just
sitting there talking to each other and
we all agree hey let's just go talk to
people hey Pat why don't you come on
this platform everybody agrees with you
I don't want to go to a platform where
everybody agrees with me I want to go on
a platform where people don't agree with
me I want people to stop me in the
middle of the street and say you know
what I don't agree with what you said
about this this I said really I don't
agree with myself also sometimes tell me
what it was about that upset you and
let's process it together I think you we
have to almost have some of those tough
conversations do something with it try
to figure out a way to persuade then if
we don't succeed then we got to take a
different route but I do think we have
to talk to the opposition side instead
of just people that agree with us you
can be a very good person that can find
your own audience there's two types of
people there's those who are going to go
give such a great message bashing the
other side so much that the people that
agree with this person show up but but
they don't convert then there's another
person that's going to say let me tell
you my way of how I see this here and
this is how I evolved into thinking this
way and then the other people say that
guy just converted me into a thinking
like that so this guy finds a community
this guy goes and converts people we
need more converters in America that's
what's lacking there are too many
cowards that are running away just to
talk to people that agree with them and
it's safe we need more Fighters that's
the challenge that we're having right
now so when that guy's saying what he's
saying I don't blame him for feeling
that way maybe he's got to take a couple
communication courses well I fully agree
with what you're saying and that the
term that we've all heard over the last
half of years is people are living in
Echo Chambers it's if you're on the left
you're just speaking to all your friends
in the left and that's who you associate
with and you're living your Echo chamber
if you're on the right you don't even
all the libtards out there I would never
hang out with anyone on the left all
their [__] evil out there they're
just living in an echo chamber what I
fully appreciate is open dialogue and I
the fact that you constantly say I'm
going to push back a little bit I'm
gonna push back a bit that pushback
right there is where you find answers
although I will that right there is
where you find actually Common Ground I
mean speaking of push back a little bit
uh Jonathan high he did this really
interesting study the idea of echo
Chambers conservatives consistently are
better able to identify what the left
believes in vice versa right because
it's frankly a little bit hard to live
in an echo chamber if you are right wing
nowadays right your your government is
left-wing your media is left-wing Your
Entertainment is left-wing your
schooling is left wing so I mean
obviously especially if you're in social
media and your friend group that could
absolutely be just full of conservatives
right-wingers you don't have any
exposure to actual leftists but you're
not going to get the same amount of
ideological Purity that you can on the
left and I think that is why the left
more so than the right has been
radicalized and that we can see this
when we look at like the positioning of
the democratic party over the past few
decades that has shifted much further
right compared to sorry much further
left compared to any transformation
that's happened I actually fully agree
with you can I Circle back to one thing
because we kind of skipped over it
you we kind of just addressed it and
then we moved on this whole concept of
tolerance pbd for years you've been
saying that your family abides by four
overriding principles what are they
again courage wisdom tolerance
understanding okay courage wisdom
tolerance understanding this isn't
something you just came up with this
week this month this year how many years
have you been saying that
15 years okay and you have a whole
artwork yes embraced on this yes and I
fully understand why you're saying that
you're grappling with this word
tolerance because it's come up so much
these days hey you got to be tolerant
you got to be tolerant whereas when you
initiated this entire uh
livelihood tolerance was a virtue
tolerance was the main what's the
definition of Tolerance willingness to
accept feelings habits or beliefs that
are different from your own right are
there some synonyms endurance resilience
being open-minded but it comes to an
extent we had when we did the interview
with Tate in Romania
when he basically went on a riff about
tolerance tolerance of what all right
okay I'll be tolerance of this okay gays
can get married all right I'm tolerant
of this all right I'm telling you that
and then you can't kind of use the story
about all right now I gotta eat the bugs
now I gotta be tolerant of eating the
bugs where do we draw the line and I
think that's we're at an inflection
point of like all right cool I'm
tolerant about this all right cool I'm
tolerant about this yeah I don't know
about these drag shows with kids I I
think not tolerant about that I still I
still think it's a good quality I don't
think it's a bad quality I think you
have to uh isolate in what areas
tolerance is bad we can be easy to jump
to one side or the other I got four kids
trust me you need tolerance I run a
business with 45 000 insurance agents in
you know 49 states trust me you need
tolerance when you're working with
people that are going through the
evolution of growing their mindset and
all this other stuff if you don't have
it if you don't have tolerance you would
fire a hundred percent of people you
hire you need a level of Tolerance what
I believe we need a level of in
intolerance towards is towards
intolerance meaning
the people I have the easiest time
working with or Community like for
example Chris Cuomo and I were talking
yesterday
and he says Pat why do you want me on
your show like dude I'm not I don't look
like the profile of people who have you
owners just to be clear you're talking
about the CNN anchor yeah
I said what do you mean it's a very
simple question for me I said first of
all I have a lot of respect for any man
who raises two boys who love each other
and are friends and are laughing and
your father did that and when I see you
and Andrew I got two boys I want my boys
to be it doesn't I don't have to only
look at conservative two sons to see how
close they are it doesn't matter what it
is I respect the fact that you guys are
tied you guys are close I see you as a
stud obviously we have opposing
political ideas and philosophies but
that's where we can have the exchange I
think you are respectful and we can have
a respectful conversation together if
people can reason we can have exchange
the people you shouldn't waste your time
talking to are the people who don't have
the ability to reason that's when you're
wasting your time this is why I said the
people that can be converted or are open
let's talk the people that are not going
to listen to any like Keith olberman
what is the conversation with Keith
Urban going to be because there's no
there's not going to be conversation
it's just going to be you're a [__]
you're a this you're gonna gotta go home
buddy it's not gonna work out this is
not what this is all about so that's all
I'm talking about with tolerance and
intolerance if I could offer perhaps The
Virtue you're seeing intolerance there
in tolerance not in intolerance there uh
isn't actually tolerance itself but
understanding because I feel like if you
can understand where someone is coming
from well that should be the defining
characteristic of whether you accept
them or not the issue of employees for
example is it really that you have to be
tolerant or that you need to be
understanding of different scenarios and
if a scenario still equals them being an
effective employee you're not going to
tolerate that no you have to no you know
no no
F2 in sales you if if you think I woke
up day one and I was the number one
sales person in my gym or office or
insurance company that would be the
biggest lie somebody was very tolerant
with my evolution of improving because
they believed in me that's a different
kind of Tolerance I tolerate Vinnie when
we first had him on the podcast no joke
you know I had a conversation with it
and I said Vinnie here's what we got to
work on and this and even with Adam I
Adam and I at the first podcast versus
today it's a very different thing but I
said is that because you understood that
they were new that they were trying to
grow and that this was not their final
evolution no I think tolerance is a very
good quality people
people who are tolerant to areas where
they believed something can improve in
areas that I'm not going to be tolerant
in my non-negotiables we're not we're
not I'm not tolerating my
non-negotiables but I think if you have
let's say you're dating somebody what is
the challenge the older you get the
harder it is to get married is there
true to that of course there is why why
is it easier to get married when you're
in your 20s why is it easier to get
married when you're in your 30s than 40s
why I mean there's a whole red pill
conversation we could well now you're
stepping in my department well yeah but
but but by the way I mean the argument
can be well you shouldn't get married
because a divorce they take half of what
he's got into this America is all about
the woman I get that what I'm trying to
tell you is the older you get the less
things you are willing to tolerate yeah
which by the way some could say that's a
good thing but if you're alone by
yourself but you want to be in a family
and have kids guess what you are a
little bit too all intolerant to too
many things you got to kind of pick what
your non-negotiables are it's the only
thing I'm talking about I want to go to
some of the other I want to give you
credit for one thing go for it okay this
is it
the reason I respect pbd so much is the
conversation we talked about one of our
first handful of podcasts and it came
down to the concept of being a leader
and specifically being a sales leader
all right you do the SLS the sales
leader Symposium sales leader Summit
every year any and and we were having a
conversation with debate and you go hold
on I'm sorry Adam what's the most amount
of people you've ever LED
I was like well you know maybe like my
sales team is like four or five guys and
I was a camp counselor as a kid I was 50
people you're like nice try buddy try
being the sales leader sales manager for
tens of thousands of people
and that put my whole narrative in
perspective and that's what I give
Peabody so much credit for speaking of
Tolerance is I mean we've been to the
MGM Grand the events that you do for PHP
shout out to those guys
thousands ten thousand people in a room
when you're leading thousands and
thousands and thousands of people I'm
more prone to listening to what you have
to say versus someone who's leading 10
people in in and by the way again
if if you and I wanted to be intolerant
to every say you're a governor say
you're a president say you're a leader
of a military oh my God one you're
miserable if you have a long list of
things to be intolerant to it's just
things are not going to get done and
everybody else is going to be walking on
eggshells all the time so let's go into
some stories let's go into some stories
by the way Jonah Hill's text did you
guys see Jonah Hill yes did you see
Jonah Hill's text yes you want to go
there yeah okay
the only reason I went there is because
she said red pill not I want your
thoughts so if you want to pull up Jonah
Hill's text and uh this is uh Adam you
didn't even know I was going to bring
this up let me bring it up so here's
Jonah Hill's acts sharing sharing texts
that they had together publicly which is
obviously a very uh Noble thing to do
and many guys of course want to date her
after she shares yeah texts of her ex
with everybody here's a text that Jonah
sent to her plain and simple if you need
surfing with men boundary less
inappropriate friendships with men to
model to post pictures of yourself in a
bathing suit to post sexual pictures
friendship with women who are in
unstable places and from your wild
recent past Beyond getting a lunch or
coffee or something respectful I am not
the right partner for you if these
things bring you to a place of happiness
I support it and there will be no hard
feelings there are my these are my
boundaries for romantic partnership my
boundaries with you based on the ways
these actions have hurt our trust when
you read this what do you say I could
not imagine a more reasonable sentiment
from a boyfriend not only that but he
communicated very very clearly and very
sensitively I felt he's essentially
saying this is what I expect in a
relationship you are currently not
meeting those standards if you want to
keep going on the way you're going
that's totally fine people have accused
him of being controlling he is not
telling her what to do he is simply
saying I will not be a part of it and
guess what women we are not entitled to
have a boyfriend to have a certain man's
time he is just setting I thought very
reasonable boundaries I know in this
social media age it's for some reason
controversial to say Hey you probably
shouldn't be posting thirst traps I
would say that period but especially if
you're in a relationship so to see
people calling Jonah Hill abusive for
this I was really surprised I was
expecting something really juicy
outrageous when I open the text and then
it's just
okay okay
Lauren you hit the nail on the head here
is that you're expecting something so
much worse than this and I was excited
for it showed us a woman beater let's
find it yeah and even if you look on
page six of New York Post that he's been
labeled a misogynist oh God abusive
actually yes uh emotional abuse is what
it's called yeah here's the actual do
uh you you hit the nail on the head when
you said boundaries and also another
word for boundaries is preferences and
this is the difference between men and
women today women have no problem and
they are not lambasted or been or been
made made fun of or ashamed for when
they say they have preferences well what
are the preferences all women want I
want a man that's six foot make six
figures I want it to be nice with my
mother I wanted to be have puppies I
wanted to treat me right I wanted to pay
on the first date I want them to tr you
know be fun be outgoing have a good
Network there's a checklist that women
want but when guys are like yeah uh
here's my checklist uh don't be a hoe
put your tits away you know don't move
thirst traps all over the Internet I'd
prefer it preferences if you don't have
a bunch of guy friends that you're
hanging out with uh and actually just be
a respectful person and don't put your
[__] out there oh my God he's an
emotionally abusive person he's a
misogynist such [__] trolling I have
a question though was she was she like
this before this happened or all of a
sudden here's the other part of the text
that's interesting because he says 25
okay but you're right we can't do serve
social things or develop trust until you
consider me and make decisions that give
regard to our relationship I have been
vulnerable as possible and I am telling
you I am needing you to step up to the
plate which you can I'm sure of it but
these losers don't get your time if you
want me straight up it's consideration I
respect your love for surfing but I
respect myself as well and your love of
Surfing and being in those situations
and lack of awareness are not mutually
exclusive this by the way the guy what a
very well spoken here
this isn't me I have my own issues that
I own I gotta love that if you want
marriage and family you can't use the 25
card step up and cut [__] these people
don't get your time or your kindness at
the sacrifice of mine those guys I mean
that seems very emotional
communicating very clearly yes by the
way do you know this is not recent
do you know that he just had a baby with
another woman yeah well a month ago
that is somewhat of the reason behind
the leak correct exactly so apparently
she waited this woman right here uh
Sarah Brady waited until
the new mother of his child his first
child is that the X that's I believe
that yes
from the lgbtq community could say that
Jonah's shown too much cleavage that's
way too much it looks great is that a
pirate ship the point is she waited
until the new baby mama had a child out
of respect to the woman now you might
say why the [__] are you even putting
these texts out there yeah a year later
right to expose Jonah Hill in my opinion
she's only exposing herself because if
she actually
made some of these concessions she could
be Jonah Hill's baby mama wife whatever
but he found someone that actually was
willing to work within his framework and
his boundaries where she's out there
just still surfing and being by herself
and this is essentially the problem with
modern day women is they're not even
willing to listen to a good guy's
requests by the way what Jonah is
sharing with her are his non-negotiables
that's all it is correct these are my
non-negotiables if you're cool with it
I'd love to make you my wife let's have
family together let's have kids together
but I'm not compromising here that's a
perfect example of somebody that can
reason
talk deliver his message but at the same
time not compromise his non-negotiables
he's got to respect him forward the
problem is that he's not supposed to
have non-negotiables he's not supposed
to have boundaries when it comes to the
behavior of his girlfriend because
feminism she should be able to do
whatever she wants whatever she wants
whatever she wants he can't have any
standards whatsoever oh take it or leave
it buddy and I think regarding your
question of was she doing this before
there are people who were saying well if
she was posting these photos before they
got into a relationship he should have
known what he was in for I think there's
that that's a good point I mean men you
know if if you're at a club I've been to
one once it was not an enjoyable
experience for me but you know if you're
looking at one club in your life it was
not good I did not have a good well
you're saying you've only been to one
club in your entire life yeah and it was
for a work event it was weird anyway you
need to get out more there
are you 30 yet no not yet okay gotcha
you're you're still young um but thank
you a lot of people online disagree but
if you're if well because it's like I'm
past 25 that's like you know oh your smv
is down the hill young lady exactly but
if you're a guy and you're looking at a
girl I a club and she's dread
provocatively and you like the way she
looks that's fine you can be attracted
for to her but don't be surprised when
she's not wife material because I think
for a lot of men what they're not
understanding and for a lot of women too
is that there's a difference between
being interested in someone physically
and maybe for hookup versus an actual
long-term relationship so maybe Jonah
Hill wasn't thinking with his with the
right part of his body there when he got
into a relationship for with her but
also I don't think it's unreasonable to
expect someone to act differently in a
relationship than out of a relationship
like I don't think that's crazy well
people don't change I actually had a
conversation with a good buddy of mine
who's a full-on Orthodox Rabbi living in
Jerusalem when I was there in Israel
seven kids and I'm like what's up dude
he's like dude I'm the same guy he's
like now I've changed like 10 I mean
this was a surfer dude wild party guy
Miami who had a a situation in his life
where he needed to make a change he goes
but I don't I'm still the same person so
maybe you change five percent ten
percent a little bit people don't do
complete 180s so if he's especially not
overnight for sure yeah
um arguably ever major major life
changes so the point is if she's the
surfer girl that's already doing this
maybe she'll change a little bit she's
not going to completely
to a 180 on her complete lifestyle just
like if I'm like hey do you want to go
out to a club Lauren it's like maybe
you'll go once but you're not going to
turn into like a party rat
yeah unfortunately I don't know I don't
know about that you think people change
exponentially no no what do you listen
yes dramatic dude I changed not 10 bro
you You Me At 19 years old versus me at
26 years old it's not it's not a little
bit of change it's it's night and day
what my what my habits have to do okay
it all depends on what life you're so if
you're sick of the life that you got and
you want to move on which Jonah's going
and getting therapy and sitting down
with people figuring out a way to how to
live his life he's being in Hollywood
you probably partied with so many people
God knows what rooms you've been in with
what types of people with how many women
would what has any experience so what
happens at one point like dude I don't
want this life I actually want to have a
family I actually want to have somebody
you can't change five ten percent you
have to change dramatically and that
pain is not easy so if she doesn't want
to give up some of the stuff that she
wants so she doesn't have to do it I
remember dating a girl loved her till
today we're very good together
Jennifer's friends with her as well but
I I got to a point with the rice Alyssa
man I don't know what we're doing next
okay you want to go to Hollywood I don't
want to do Hollywood I want to go be a
businessman and but man we like each
other's company everything's good here's
what I want to do what's that I'm an
atheist I don't believe in god let's go
to church together what are you becoming
religious no all I'm saying is if we're
going to take the next step of getting
married I kind of need help I don't have
a manual and we got to go belong to some
kind of a church something to learn so
that month of me going through that
process for her was so dramatic that she
didn't want to do it and for me I didn't
want to live the life that I was living
I made a massive shift in my life which
by the way when you do make a massive
shift in your life like for her she's
been the same for a long time from the
standpoint of values when she was the
way she was in high school she's the
same as she is today when she said she
hasn't done drunk she's been to one club
and because of work and all this other
stuff that's probably your entire life
for 29 years that's not the case with me
I woke up and I said I'm done the day I
woke up and I said I was done I probably
if I give you a number I probably lost
20 people in my life overnight
20 people might go into Dublin's crew my
going to Garden of Eden crew my going on
pimps and host crew in Las Vegas my crew
of going to you know these every one of
those Saddle Ranch crew my you know
pulled Charles Billiards every one of
those I lost the girls I lost all of
them because what are you doing what
happened to you all of a sudden so some
you know they're in an upbringing stable
things are more solid all this stuff
some are not if you do want a dramatic
change like let's just say you want to
have a wife and kid if you truly like
what Vinnie's doing right now give you
an idea
Vinnie
um all of a sudden I'm at church I'm
like I see Vinnie them like what's
Vinnie doing there okay that's kind of
crazy and then Vinnie gets baptized it's
like six weeks I'm like what is Vinnie
doing over there and I'll go record it
from the sound like this is the same
thing yeah you're telling me story about
a girl you know what's good with your
lips getting swollen all of a sudden why
and if he's not doing this and he's not
doing that and then we go we take him to
Bahamas I'm like damn Vinny's not
changed in the last six weeks after the
Tate visit or whatever while on the
flight back he makes a massive decision
Mario's inviting him to church Aaron
invited him all this stuff Vinnie's made
a dramatic shift in his lifestyle guess
what the people he was kicking with
eight weeks ago probably don't like him
right now nope the people he was
chilling with girls like hey can I come
over at 11 o'clock nah girl you can
right now what happened to you yeah what
happened to the old fun Vinnie that's
the [__] you're gonna hear so
there's different situations that people
have for some that we live the wildlife
and we want to make a big change you
have to be ready like Jonah is to be
able to say I lost this Grand store fine
you got to make that decision as a man
it's tough to do so it's not easy trust
me but you're a friend that's ten
percent chance and seven years old
that's fine that's not the case with
everybody I will I'll say this when you
say it's not the case with everybody
I'll I'll make make the case that it's
not the case with barely anybody yeah
like what you're saying is an anomaly
pbd how many guys that are gang bang in
LA or whatever are like yep I made a
complete change in my lifestyle I'm a
complete family man now I've started a
business I'm sorry you're an anomaly and
respect to you for that so most people
are not making dramatic changes I don't
think so I'll give you an example I
don't if Vinnie's going to church now
awesome Mazel Tov right amazing
I I have I have not noticed any
difference in Vinnie and and respect I
mean it's still the same guy he might so
here's my point your habits might change
your lifestyle might change
exactly that's my point it doesn't
change that's my point no it's not your
decisions may change but your
personality is not changing no no no no
no no that's my point you can change
your personality okay exactly yeah you
can't change your personality but you
can't change who you are you can change
your decisions the question though is
being a whole personality or a lifestyle
oh well say this again is being a whole
personality or a lifestyle oh it's a
lifestyle girl is I also think it's part
personality because there are girls that
I went to school with in high school and
you know they weren't at the time doing
anything I don't think and then oh
you're pregnant two years later at a
wedlock that was not a shock to me even
though the lifestyle they were living at
the time wasn't that but just based on
their personalities I knew that was
gonna happen I knew there was going to
be trouble in 1973 Gallop did a poll
okay
ask in what percentage of gays in
America were born that way
and what percentage of gays in America
were gay because their environment
what do you think the percentage was in
Gallup when they said what percentage of
uh gays were gay because of the they
were born that way Gallop this is like
70s I would say at that time most of
them would have said or most people
would say it was because they were wait
are they asking environment or born so
this is a nature versus nurture question
oh they're asking the the American
people in America to because this guy
would say nurture
before you give the results can we all
guess on this yeah I want you to get
okay go ahead so if you would just
rephrase it one more time okay so back
in 19 late 70s they did a poll in
America for asking people
who are gay yeah do you think they were
born that way they were born gay or
because of their environment people in
the 70s would have said that it was
because of their environment okay yeah
what do you say it is is it a percentage
Yeah I would say uh born
40 60 environment okay check this out I
said 30 I'd say 30 13 said they were
born that way today's 49 okay oh wow
okay during that time when they said 13
born that way
50 something percent said was because of
their environment so to go back to your
question about a hoe most holes their
environments affect them a lot who you
party with you have to pick up whole
Tendencies there was a famous poet named
ludicrous that said it right
he's a great poet he's a great poet a
lot of different area codes right
and see Pat don't change they don't
quote ludicrous but it's free 2004 y'all
okay but but the point is environment
has a big impact upbringing has a big
impact people you befriend has a big
impact and a part of it is your own
attractiveness to that which is part of
your DNA but I'm not going to say it's
that big of a percentage you you become
a hoe you're not born a whole kit
doesn't born go ahead you know what I'm
saying this is my entire life I know you
pick up some of those bad habits so to
go back some of us may have not had
whole Tendencies some of us may have had
lazy Tendencies some of us may have had
you know splurging Tendencies some of
them may have had you know smoking weak
Tendencies or cocaine or ecstasy or
special care whatever you want to talk
so we all had different different
Tendencies and then some people change
dramatically some don't but all in all
Jonah Hill shout out to you respect
happy he had a kid a month ago
congratulations I'm so freaking happy
for that guy yes I am so happy for the
life changing for what he's doing and
he's a sick incredible talented actor
himself maybe one of the most
entertaining ones to watch but he does a
serious movie or a funny movie you guys
are for no doubt incredible super bad
yeah Wolf of Wall Street and just quick
shout out shout out to you Vinnie for
easing up on your whole Tendencies and
going to church respect to you bro thank
you I appreciate it it was uh it was
just it was random it wasn't like nobody
I'm not saying they didn't invite me or
anything it was just like you said you
kept you get to a point where he's like
wait a minute what am I something in
here said to do it and it's just like
now you like I have a whole different
lens in life and environment environment
I mean a 100 environment works yeah the
right environment you know because some
people might consider it called growing
up bro don't ever say the Jeep Rob let's
go to the MSNBC story apparently
everybody here is a is a right wing uh
if you do work out do you know the story
I'm talking about no yes okay go to my
tweet if you want I have it all the way
at the top you'll find a story
uh you go you go to the top yeah there
you go uh click on it yeah they go a
little lower a little lower the lower
boom right there MSNBC uh zoom in uh it
says uh uh um no go back to the tweet on
how they tweeted it okay it says the far
right obsession with Fitness is going
digital
tell me that's not crazy wait that's far
right so I I retweeted it and I put
something at the top I said does the
opposite also me go a little lower does
the opposite also mean it's true the far
left Obsession would be in fat and lazy
is going digital ironically yes
yeah so if you work at even Joe said
wait a minute now if I work out I'm a
right wing forward right yeah all right
yeah like by the way let's say if they
are saying that okay so so moving
forward every time I see somebody who is
willing to take the time to work out
their disciplined with their diet they
go to the gym three four times they're
detailed with you know chest and back
and shoulders and triceps or bison tries
and legs and they're very disciplined
with all that stuff that's a right wing
well guess what you know you know what
the Republicans should do they should
use this and say guess what yeah yeah we
are we like to say hello lean into it
you guys like vaccines we like to work
out yeah you guys like to use like even
Peter Hotel say do you work here no not
really what do you do I eat a lot of
junk food don't you think that's bad
food do you take vitamins Now Vitamins
don't really work you know I only take
vaccines really yeah well they're
talking about studies about this if you
are a man and you go to the gym and you
work out and you have higher
testosterone you are more likely to be
right wing than correct
wing and I don't think it's a mystery as
to why because a lot of the I guess
mentality that would lead to someone
going to the gym self-improvement
personal response responsibility
discipline those are more inherently
conservative than socialists not to
mention just the I guess you know if you
go to the gym your testosterone levels
are going to be higher because you're
exercising and being having a higher
testosterone level is more commonly
associated with right-wing values
because it's like you're you're less
effeminate less willing to nurture
redistribute all those so you're saying
most steroids dealers are Republicans
[Laughter]
a better artist yeah well just look at
the UFC the UFC I mean I'm not going to
say everyone who's a pro fighter is
going to be Republican or right-wing but
that is one of the few Sports where I
think you see a lot a lot of even if
they're not openly we like I know for a
fact that a lot of people in that sphere
professional fighting they are
conservative they do lean right oh when
they see Trump they like a fighter this
past weekend out of the ring and was
like Mr Trump like I love you but it's
not well I didn't know that going to the
gym like yeah well I'm a racist Jesus
that's right it's so absurd there are to
to confirm what you're saying there have
been studies out there that attribute
being a little bit more attractive to
being a little bit more conservative
right-wing free thinking because it
comes down to
personal accountability right and that's
really what it comes down to there's
multiple studies like this but this to
me I'd like to see the studies they get
where it just seems [__] on the
surface because I know so many people
left right center up down gay straight
who just are want to look good take care
of themselves I mean I live in Miami and
South Beach you have no idea how many
gay guys are out there looking [__]
they look great no I mean I'm not into
that thing but whatever whatever great
but it's it's just so absurd so I I
fully agree with Pat
if you're on the GOP embrace the hell
out of this the left are just fat sloppy
lazy losers wait uh relying on vaccines
and you're taking personal
accountability and personal
responsibility for your health if you're
on the right
it's a bad look for yeah for MSNBC to
write that I I I would run with it I'm
telling you if I'm on the other side I'm
on a run even MSNBC says you know we're
in shape we have the right habits and
the other side doesn't anyways next
story since you're talking about this
Trump shares a jovial handshake with Joe
Rogan who once called them a man baby
and an existential threat to democracy
former Donald Trump shared a friendly
handshake with Joe Rogan at the UFC
fight in Las Vegas despite Rogan
previously Colin Trump a man baby Trump
enthusiastically approached Rogan at the
event and the two engage in a
a friendly conversation a 10 second
handshake Rogan has been critical of
trump in the past referring to him as a
man baby and declining opportunities to
interview him Rogan expresses lack of
support for Trump stating that he
doesn't want to help him and Views him
as an existential threat to democracy
despite their differences Trump and
Rogan had a cordial interaction at the
UFC fight that's that good question
the question becomes a follow-up okay
when you see this okay if you look at
this because I want you to see this go
back to the handshake to show this you
know I love these handshake they're the
most aggressive Trump is always playing
tug of war
he's like get in here watch watch I love
he goes you're a good guy you're a good
look at you good JC is complimenting
Rogan yeah thank you thank you he said
we should have a talk so here's the
question yes sir over under the podcast
taking place with Trump and Roku 80 yes
it's gonna happen I say I think it is
gonna happen I'm not going to give a
percentage but give a percentage Lauren
take a risk 67. oh wow that it's
happened two-thirds this is how she's
doing it I think 80 where are you going
with this well I'm asking you I asked
okay that looks like he has an Insider
uh look at Pat's grin see that it's
cheating if you're Pat has that look
that his son has when he knows it messed
up yeah Pat knows see that laugh all
right so you want to go first well I'll
just cite two quotes you set up the man
baby thing that was on a podcast he did
with Tom Segura in 2022. it's not a 2016
conversation and then in 2022 Rogan had
a podcast with Lex Friedman and he said
uh he was asked multiple times to do a
podcast he said no no no no no no every
single time quote unquote I have no
interest in helping him this is in 2022
so as of a year ago it was zero percent
I think at this point based on the UFC
audience how things have changed quite
significantly I will give it a and I
think it's a high number 20 what wow yes
but it goes up what you what what you
what you're saying 80 you're saying he's
gonna do it and Pat this just goes into
what we just talked about like tolerance
and like he's changing as a person like
bro he's seeing the like he Joe Rogan
was anti-trump on everything right now
but now that he's seeing what the left
has done he's pro-trump right now I
don't care what anybody says bro he's
shaking his hands smiling when he was a
fan he called him a man baby a year ago
a year ago well a year a lot can change
in a year
it doesn't mean he doesn't want to
interview him you want to play I'm just
glad that he's still considered a man
yeah oh is that what you're talking
about what he said what do you say here
this is the Lex Friedman interview from
last year where he said he won an
interview play it Rob Lex fredman why
fredman I don't know not a Friedman Rob
well he didn't want to say that because
Rob's been going to the gym so he
doesn't want to be a
shakes hands with people that aren't
even there when he gets off stage yeah I
think he's seeing ghosts you see him on
Jimmy Kimmel the other day no well he
was just rambling I mean he's if he was
anyone else if he was a republican if
that was Donald Trump doing that every
[__] talk show would be screaming for
him to be off the air and by the way I'm
not a trump supporter in any way shape
or form I've had the opportunity to have
him on my show more than once I've said
no every time I don't want to help him
I'm not interested in helping him the
the Knight is still young we'll see if I
have mon the Knight is still young I
think I'll have him on yeah I think
you'll have him on really why do you
think that because you'll have Putin on
your computer
you can pause it right there what's the
date on that time stamp that this is
2020.
the thing about this I don't want to
help him but the by
has no idea he's not making decisions
they have they have [__] on this country
so much now it's not what now he's gonna
help him no now he he's a prime example
of seeing just what the media and
everybody did to the left God and what
no no before Pat Reveals His results
yeah you want to have a bet let's have a
bet all right I bet you a thousand
dollars a thousand bucks that he does
not have him on that he doesn't
interview him correct wait by when by oh
God by the time that Trump presidency is
is or or is not the president before
November 2nd or third sure you're saying
a thousand dollars he doesn't interview
him yeah
it's a good bet
I'll go 500 bucks
Hey listen Penny what happened to having
conviction no no what happened
500 bucks is a big number 500 bucks
700. Adam five years you want to do it
all right I don't usually do bets for
less than a thousand five minutes
I'll pay it we'll pay it live verbal
agreement
buy the election you're saying it's not
good for election correct and if it
happens I pay you 500 bucks that's 500
and if it doesn't happen got you so
here's what I would say yeah so here's
what I would say I think the the one
thing that's been very consistent with
Joe Rogan over the years that he's so
open-minded that his positions can
change yeah okay he never thought he
would have RFK on before okay and now he
had RFK on even the opening he says look
I thought you were alone I thought this
I thought that I thought this but then
listen I met you Casa D'Angelo okay you
know but whatever no he didn't say casa
I Met You in uh Aspen we talked I'm like
okay I want to have you on and I you
know I thought it was all this vaccine
stuff and I was a guy that was a vaccine
person but you're making a lot of sense
that I read the book okay great he's
done this so many times he went from
Bernie Sanders to Saint voting
Republican okay correct the evolution so
meaning there is that Evolution with Joe
for this to take place here's the other
part the whole concept about
uh uh I've shared with Joe what my
thoughts are on on the interview with
Trump he he knows it but
um
the idea about I don't want to help him
has to be replaced in my opinion you're
not helping him you're helping America
meaning if the idea is you don't want to
help America I think Joe you want to
help America and you've been helping
America in my opinion you're the number
one guy you're the goat when it comes
down to podcasting and not only that
during covet the the most super
necessary guy in America
was him Forget before musk buying
Twitter in October of 2022 before any of
that it was Joe Rogan not Dr fauci Pat
no no so so so the point the point I'm
trying to make is yeah if you believe
America needs to see the opposing side
of the argument I think Joe needs to
have uh Trump on I think he needs to
have the Santa son I think he needs to
have Newsom on uh because I think it's
going to be Newsom Biden won't go they
wouldn't know
but I would die to see that but I would
love this you know what I would love to
see if since he smokes weed with Elon
Musk I would love to see Joe Rogan smoke
crack with Hunter Bible I just I mean
Joe doesn't need to smoke it
I think that would be viewed
an island
well I'm here
I think eventually uh it's more likely
to happen I'm more 55 yes
saying he doesn't want to help him but
it seems like at least with RFK his
approach wasn't necessarily I'm helping
you or not helping you it's just we're
just having a conversation and people
can decide and you know if Trump is an
idiot if he's uh an extremist if he's
whatever sitting down for three hours
people are gonna see through that so it
might even hurt him who knows but I
think his audience would decide and I
think Rogan likes to be clear I I
actually would like to see that
interview I'm actually I'll gladly lose
500 if it means to see that interview I
think it'd be amazing but I think we're
doing a disservice to uh Trump to
compare rfk's
viewpoints to where how he feels about
Trump this is this has nothing to do
with RFK no that's what I'm saying he he
criticized some of his views but he
still had him on no it's a different
Beast with Trump what do you mean with
with how the interview with Trump's
going to do versus his feelings about
RFK were not as Intense or exaggerated
as they are with Trump he never called
RFK a man baby yeah and he never said he
would never want to have a very
interesting individual with a high
self-awareness and a level of comfort of
being wrong and a level of conflict
conviction in areas where he is certain
that he's right and you know this is
this is a guy that if there's a guy that
uh you know would be able to you know
interview would be able to change his
position and be open to the idea it's
Joe and if that happens so I'll let you
guys know if that happens he's done 2024
Doug it's gonna be like hey Kiss It
Goodbye everybody else call home pack
you know play your video games I
understand what you're saying and you're
saying that if he has him on that that
will mean Trump will win the White House
if he has them on uh okay so for example
Maria Bartiromo let me just read this to
you okay and this this is kind of Mario
Bartolo confronts DeSantis on 2024
campaign what happened right this is a
Newsweek story and if you want to pull
up the clip if you actually have the
clip I don't know if you got it or not
if you can just go to that part where he
asks she asked the question uh uh is
this yeah this is the part go ahead and
play it watch this back against woke we
know that but I'm wondering what's going
on with your campaign there was a lot of
optimism about you running for president
earlier in the year but here's this
weekend's headline from the Politico
Playbook Failure to Launch Florida
Governor Ron desantis's campaign to
topple Donald Trump has stalled we are
way behind says a top DeSantis pack
official sounding the alarm what
happened
um Maria these are narratives the media
does not want me to be the nominee I
think that's very very clear why because
they know I'll beat Biden but even more
importantly they know I will actually
deliver on all these things we will stop
The Invasion at the border we'll take on
the drug cartels we'll curtail the
administrative State we'll get spending
under control we'll do all the things
that they don't want uh to see done and
so they're going to continue doing the
type of narrative I can tell you we
understand this as a state-by-state
process we've had incredible support in
the early states building an
organization signing up the key people
that you need to be able to compete in a
place like Iowa we just launched our
model okay you can pause it right there
here's the thing by the way he ain't
lying meaning
he wouldn't make one hell of a president
I agree he would have incredible
policies he would do all of those things
but you're going up against a guy that's
a marketer and your marketing team sucks
it's absolutely sucks since the book
came out the Razzle Dazzle of trump he
needs to throw in some horse faces
like a comments
some excitement
you need something
I hooked up with the Santa 17 years ago
the point I'm trying to make is yeah you
know
so there's one you have an incredible
resume check you have it two is
you're going into the interview okay
the person you already got the interview
like you got the people you're being
considered for the job you're a finalist
you're in the top three finalists to be
considered for the job so the resume got
you into the interview
then you have to crush the interview
and you ruin the interview
if Trump goes in with the resume
and then he goes in the interview that's
where he shines he's shining when the
interview begins this guy's like here's
my resume let me tell you what I've done
this is why you should pick me that's
not how America works well it's funny
because for so long people have been
critical of trump being unpredictable
kind of brash and abrasive but it turns
out that maybe you need a candidate with
at least a little bit of that because
you have someone like Rhonda Sanders I
like Trump I like Rhonda santis I don't
think it needs to be either or but he
doesn't have the same star power the
same Charisma which in politics let's be
real of course That Matters by the way
okay so let's let's do this let's do
this uh the star power by the way his
team I've communicated with both teams
with Trump's team with his team with
rfk's team with vivex team we're in
communication with every one of the
teams Suarez do you know which team
sucks in follow-up or getting back to us
they text in a text and then boom okay
I'm available this afternoon great no
follow-up for two weeks they're the
worse in follow-up it's a reflection of
the brand it's not a good look and this
is not like it's a small podcast we got
17 subscribers and you're doing this
with we got a platform to say this to
the market your follow-up sucks with
people that are reaching out to you and
we communicate with every campaign so
you're talking about the an FYI I keep
saying this we came here because of this
guy we're in Florida because of this guy
I've moved I don't know how many people
we've moved out if I tell you in the
last 26 months 28 months if I told tell
you 1500 people have moved to Florida
because of what we've done that would be
a small number we've moved a couple
thousand people to Florida with the
amount of times we've raved about him
raved about the state we've moved people
to the state and these are high quality
people that we move to the state these
are not non-performing people these are
job creators entrepreneurs that we have
moved to this state there is support
there
you're saying you have to be able to
sell yourself right okay
let me give you another example of
somebody
that I think campaign to campaign
campaign to campaign vivec is crushing
their campaign and Vivek had nothing who
was Vivek well I mean he was a
best-selling author multi-millionaire
entrepreneur no but but the difference
is but but the difference is let me let
me put it to you this way day one when
vivec announced his running for office
do you know what his Twitter account was
at 40 000 followers sixty thousand
followers I'm sorry even the woke book
he wrote it didn't blow up can you go to
Amazon go to Amazon and type in vivec go
to Amazon and type in Vivek we had him
on and he and I we spoke yesterday go go
online and put his name there okay when
he first came out with his walk book
just type in Vivek ramazwani and go to
his book uh uh okay how many uh what is
that that's Vivek what year 2023 how
many months ago uh yeah this book came
out April of 2023 it has uh 47 reviews
okay go to the next book that by the way
57 reviews to be fair guys and I like
this guy that's nothing nation of
victims how many reviews is that 372
reviews a year ago that's barely selling
30 000 copies by the way just so you
know that that number on Amazon that's
nothing but what has this guy done
here's what he's done he went on
Charlemagne the God The Breakfast Club
you know what they try to do to him
destroy him you know what he did he
stood his ground he went on new CNN same
with CNN you went on CNN he went on he's
gone everywhere he's not said no to
anything and he stood his ground when
Don Lemon tried to embarrass him he
stood his ground he says that's fine you
can believe that but we can disagree and
he was so respectful about it the way
ramaswani went out there saying I'm Not
Afraid him and RFK get A's in the way
they've gone out talking the scientist's
camp is thinking they're entitled to
that to the throne and you don't get the
championship ring given to you you got
to go earn that stuff by the way whether
you're injured whether you're not in the
mood when you're going to the playoffs
on Sports what happens during playoffs
what does everybody say during playoffs
when people do the interviews like when
Joel embiid says well it was really hurt
and I was this you know what Champions
say listen when you're in the playoffs
everybody is at 50 60 everybody's
dealing with an injury you got a finger
you got a knee you gotta you gotta this
you got it that you don't have a choice
you have to show up in the playoffs
right
it's very disappointing and by the way
yesterday we're having this conversation
with a group of people and some of the
guys said he's the modern day Jeb Bush
and he's a modern-day Skywalker that's
nothing hang on a second the modern day
Jeb Bush and the modern day Scott Walker
not because of resume his resume is
possibly the greatest governor in the
last 30 years since I've been in America
no one's got a better resume than him
but his campaign is Jeb Bush and Scott
Walker 2.0 and Pat you were you you've
been saying this not not to cut you off
you've been saying this for how long
about the marketing team and everything
about him my question is as as being at
the candidate being descended how does
he not see it are you not hearing like
she's she just said it the the people
are seeing your numbers are showing it
does he need to just do a complete shift
patent like fire somebody or hire a
better marketing team they are horrible
how they not texting somebody back that
is like yo I have this platform Millions
not just I have a platform I'll do a
fundraiser for you yeah we'll raise a
ton of money yeah we'll get you eyeballs
we'll have a fair interview with you
because we respect you let's have this
exchange multiple times the team doesn't
get back not one time well I'm not going
to give names yet okay but I'm gonna
give names within a year multiple times
they don't get back to you multiple
times they don't get back to you and by
the way I'm not the only one saying that
as well making Kelly have you say Megan
Kelly is one of the greatest she's a top
five in the last 10 years what are you
doing not going on Megan Kelly what are
you doing not going on any of this stuff
what are you doing not going on Lex free
I don't know has Lex done a podcast with
DeSantis yet no I don't think so I don't
believe it can you look it up what are
you doing not going on Lex Lex is a very
very nice guy Lex is a sweetheart of a
guy that's going to ask you questions
but he's so respectful about it how come
you haven't gone on legs and it'll be
fair to you as well can I just give some
quick numbers just to validate exactly
what you're saying in February what
month are we in right now July July so
less than six months ago go up Rob just
to the top to the top left ahead the
Republican primary polls boom in
February between Trump and DeSantis neck
and neck yeah look at that yeah to the
left they were one was at 38 one was at
42 percent anyone's race anyone's race
in February Failure to Launch what do
they call his campaign his book came out
six months before he actually announced
Pat's called out his marketing team now
go to all the way to the right just look
at the numbers Trump said 52 percent
DeSantis has plummeted from 38 down to
what is that less than 20.
24 what is that Rob
doesn't sit here on the track but it's
hovering right around between 20 like
23. the point is this whatever he's
doing it's fair to say is not working so
he should change you should change
things up even you gotta adjust you
gotta adapt yeah I'm in Florida for two
you gotta go into halftime and say
listen guys someone's got to give a
halftime speech
change it up a little bit go ahead yeah
I mean I'm in Florida for TP USA and we
have a sister organization Turning Point
action there's a huge conference I mean
Trump is speaking Tucker Carlson is
speaking DeSantis isn't speaking I'm not
part of that organization you know it's
just they're they're separate because
the Santa's really not speaking he's not
speaking I mean he hasn't been announced
yet and some people there are some
people are wondering why he isn't there
is it because he doesn't want to go in
the same event be speaking with Trump
and I I don't know but I would love to
see more of him because he's been one of
like you said the most effective
Governors he's been aggressive in his
policy which I love he's not one of
these Republicans who is simply trying
to be on offense all the time he's
actually saying okay parental rights and
education boom let's do it let's go
after Disney we're not just gonna talk
which I love I've been in communication
with his administration there was a
video that I shared of uh this topless
trans stripper with a I mean she looked
like four years old it wasn't just talk
for the campaign they're actually doing
things about it they're trying to do an
investigation see if they should keep
their liquor license I love how
effective they are but like you said the
campaign it just it's Gotta show up
listen when you get to the interview you
best deliver when you're sitting across
the decision maker you know who the
decision maker right now is America
and Americans right now are saying no
you're not fit for the job yet maybe
never FYI I'll never forget I will never
forget
when the Pacers are playing the Miami
Heat
and timeout is called Indiana is up one
this is game two game three they're
about to go up 2-1 this is 2012. yes yes
11 years ago yes okay they're up one
coach Vogel takes out Roy Hibbert who
was the center of starter All-Star game
he takes Hibbert out
and like what are you doing there's two
seconds left on the shot clock
Hibbert's on the sideline shaking and
said what are you doing taking me out
Miami takes the ball gives it to LeBron
at the free throw line LeBron goes this
way fakes going with a left hand they
win the game afterwards they're talking
TNT and Chuck says well you know the
Frank's got to tell him right now we're
so close and this is our chance to go to
the championship and Kenny Smith says no
Charles I disagree he says what do you
mean you disagree he says this may have
been their last chance to ever win a
championship wow
these players don't realize when you get
an opportunity like this championships
are not handed out you should have kept
Hibbert in what are you doing taking
them out guess what he was right he
would win like this after that nobody
ever talked about him again and that
entire team Paul George everybody they
had collapsed vocal everybody went all
over the place
this idea of thinking well this doesn't
work we'll do 28 if this doesn't run
Skywalker this one object which is
another story no this is not how life
works you have the sickest resume today
you crushed it under covid you even had
MBA like the story talent why are you
not talking about the most liberal BLM
think about the hypocrisy NBA had BLM
all over the place and as much as that
BLM all over the place they chose to
hold the All-Star Game in your state
while you're the governor how the hell
are you not telling that story you
crushed it and you're not telling that
story I don't understand this stuff it's
so confusing this should have been like
this Trump and DeSantis should have been
like this and by the way that's better
for America if it would have been like
this because they're pushing issues
there is no issues right now we're not
hearing any issues right now all we're
seeing is this it's over for most people
some people say why should even Trump
get on the stage can you imagine if
Trump doesn't even get on the stage
doesn't need to listen did you get on
the stage Marie asked him a question are
you going to be on the stage
so well yeah of course I'm going to be
doing the debate but this is you have to
win by the state and all this other
stuff no not for for president yes it's
by State but not for Republican that's
for yep anyways so it's a whole
different story on what's going on here
so for me Trump goes on Rogan
he's gonna put on a show you know what
he's going to do he's going to do
flattery Joe you're the greatest you
know this this this that all of that
stuff's gonna happen they're going to
connect they're gonna laugh he's gonna
make Joe laugh his ass off those clips
are going to be put up at the end of it
Joe's probably you know Hey sir I got to
tell you my position here but I really
enjoyed you with you hopefully you're
gonna kind of tone it down a little bit
with the way you do this this with
tweets it says I'm working on it and
then boom the world's gonna see that and
humanize him and the rest is history
these are some of the things that if
Trump gets that opportunity to be on Joe
he'll capitalize I think so too can I
just add one thing because I know our
audience isn't a sports audience so yeah
I'm not gonna lie that was lost but I
like that I got that but here's the deal
what he's saying is carpe diem
this is the mother freaking day
in February that here are the numbers 40
Trump 38 DeSantis now it's 52-21 he
tells this random 2012 NBA playoff story
as a metaphor the Indiana Pacers were
this close to dethroning to the Miami
Heat and LeBron James what has happened
since then since this stupid decision
that the coach made Indiana Pacers have
barely even made it the playoffs that
team has been dismantled Danny Granger
Paul George Roy Edward is out of the
league meanwhile LeBron James AKA Trump
in this story has won four NBA
championships since then he's still the
face of the league meanwhile the other
players are out of the freaking League
he also brought up Scott Walker Jeb Bush
these people are in the in the Dustbin
of history and that could potentially
happen to DeSantis
no no they don't get a second shot do
you think he should have waited until
the next election cycle no not at all
because a lot of people are saying oh
I'm sorry till the next elections oh
yeah I'm sorry I thought you were saying
you you should have waited to go on
later oh no you're saying to go 2028.
okay that's a very good question I I
think he should have ran because you're
gonna forget we we forget things very
quickly America as much as America can
[__] and complain were so forgiven so
quickly and we move on you know we we
like to see you fall but we like you
come up even more we love Redemption
stories this is America America is a
place that we're like hey man you're
losing your morning did you see the
juicy did you just oh [__] I feel bad
hey it's okay yeah it's okay that's
America right that's kind of America so
that's what's going to happen with Trump
but he had his moment it was so clear so
clear
marketing team sucked who wasn't his ear
sucked whoever he hired
it's uh it's it's unfortunate and by the
way again this is coming from an
Community who are fans who are
supporters who voted
unanimously like in every possible way
it's for you and you did this anyways
watch what's happening here to
transition this story ramaswani closes
in on the sentence as Trump dominates in
GOP Paul the hill former president Trump
leads the GOP Primary uh field with 49
support according to recent poll by
Echelon insights Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis follows in second place with 16
while biotech entrepreneur Vivek
ramaswan is behind them with 10 ramas
money has been a two percentage Point
increase in support since a previous
poll conducted in May where he had eight
percent in contrast DeSantis has
experienced a three percentage drop
since May when he guarded 19 points
Congress concerns with the sentences
viability as a candidate has emerged
particularly following a glitchy Twitter
spaces I'm not worried about that one
right there his recent criticism of
trump post
support for LGBT community has drawn
backlash from GOP groups such as Log
Cabin Republicans those things I'm not
concerned about but the part is vivec
okay why why do you think vivec is
getting this surge what do you think is
getting Kim to get people to say man I
kind of like this guy I kind of like
what he has to say he's not scared to
open his mouth Pat like just yesterday I
think it was yesterday some uh lady in
the back uh he was doing some some talk
in like a like not an auditorium like an
open area and she's like Town Hall she's
like it's my body my choice I've
exchange where the lady was willing he's
like no no come back here let's have a
conversation she came to the stage she
started crying he's having I think he's
not scared to talk he's not scared to
voice the pain and Pat marketing he's
not saying no
and he's smart as hell and he's probably
one of the most efficient and effective
communicators that's running right now
regardless of whether you like him or
not he has his hand on the pulse of
cultural issues which would have been
desantis's I guess his trump card all
right I mean he's someone who's actually
not just talking about the culture War
he's actively fighting it but he doesn't
do a good job articulating it in the
same way that Vivek does I mean he he's
he's been on the daily wire before he
even announced he is very very he knows
what the average voter cares about and I
think if we look at what happened in
Virginia with Glenn junking yankin I
mean this isn't just oh culture War
stuff it doesn't matter no these issues
they're getting people out and they're
getting especially Suburban moms to vote
so I think he's really playing his cards
right just overall yeah I I love the way
he communicates I love the way how
respectful he is I love the way he
pushes back but more importantly I love
how hard he's working he's everywhere
you know what's one of the most
intimidating things to do to your
competitors I love doing this in the
insurance space or any kind of business
when we were first coming up in our
podcast that small YouTube channel we
had like 50 000 Subs okay valuetainment
we got four and a half million not the
time was 50 000 subs and I'm in Dallas
who the hell wants to interview in
Dallas nobody wants to go to freaking
Dallas the only people that are in
Dallas are the conservatives the only
person I had was the blaze at nobody
else I want to interview everybody but
everyone's in that everyone's in La
Miami all this stuff you know what we
did we'd go to New York I'd rent a hotel
room and I would do six seven eight
interviews in two days back to back to
back to back so I got notes like this
next guest next guest next guest next
guest next guest would go to Miami seven
interviews we'd go to La 12 interviews
and then we would have enough interviews
over the next two three four weeks while
I'm running a company while we're having
baby after baby after baby while I'm
going National visiting office all this
stuff is happening it's so intimidating
to see vivec everywhere it's as if he's
got triplets it's him and two other
brothers yeah one minute this year next
minute is they say how the hell are you
everywhere that is so draining to your
enemy to your competitors to say yeah
I'm not willing to do this unless if
you're willing to come to Tallahassee to
interview me I'm not going anywhere yeah
you're going to lose to God like this
yeah you don't lose to a guy like this
that's willing to go everywhere and
anywhere to talk to anybody he's gaining
that kind of respect by the way if you
would like to see us do a live podcast
at 59.90 live with vivec I'm talking
town hall where you can ask him
questions if you would like to do that
text award podcast to
310-340-1132-310-340-1132 text award
podcast at that number we are thinking
about who to have next I'm doing a July
20th live podcast those tickets that
have already sold out but the next one
we're doing we're talking to potentially
many different camps if you'd like to
see a live podcast with Vivek again text
award podcast to
310-340-1132 next topic sound of Freedom
have you seen the movie yet so a lot of
people have asked me this uh as a new
mom I don't think I can emotionally
handle it just because of the subject
matter and I I cry during Pixar movies
that would be a total mess have you seen
Elemental I yes I did get it I didn't
even like the movie I got teary ad I'm
very very easy so so I saw the movie so
here's what happens we're in uh Bahamas
uh and we're trying to find movie
theater to go see this we can't find it
finally tikra finds the movie I'm like
[__] we're going with 25 of us and the
kids want to watch Indiana Jones what do
we do so Indiana Jones is playing at one
o'clock sound of freedoms playing at two
uh two o'clock good news Indiana Jones a
two and a half hour movie which is great
because we got like a 30 minute so we go
into Indiana Jones we're watching
Indiana Jones and then me Matt sapala
Sheena tikram with sneak out and we go
to what sound of Freedom we're sitting
there
and from the beginning you're going to
feel the pain of the father taking his
kids a daughter and a son who is
approached by a recruiter saying your
kids can be models they can be in movies
he says tonight audition is at such and
such time today the audition is
tomorrow's audition is such a such time
father dresses in a suit takes him to
this room
and he takes the kids there they're
excited put the kids in the room and the
girl says come back to pick them up at
seven o'clock he said what do you mean
come back to pick him up at seven
o'clock he leaves comes back seven
o'clock no one's there shut down that's
how the movie starts by the way
it's disturbing it's emotional it's
tough it's painful at the end Jim
Caviezel gives a message when the movie
ends three minutes later he's given a
message profound message that you have
to watch
the stats that they gave that uh 20 plus
million child pornography pictures were
uploaded on the internet the last year a
five thousand percent increase in the
last five years the idea what they said
every year two million kids going to
trafficking going into being sold in a
black market and then stats about how
you can sell cocaine one time but you
can sell the same child five to ten
times a day for 10 years is what you can
do and it's a 150 billion dollar a year
industry and Jim is in it the story of
Tim Ballard what he did and then while
this is going on everybody everybody
needs to go watch it I'm taking I want
to watch it first it's a decision you
need to make I want to watch it first I
know what it is to be a you know I don't
know what it is to be a mother but I
have a wife that's had four kids and I
know how tough it is for a mother to see
it then a father our perspective is more
protective yours is more you gave birth
it's your body
um I recommend everybody to go watch
this thing here and share it with
everyone you know because this has
really taken place this led us to
yesterday having a conversation with
many of the people in Glendale that are
going through the challenges they're
having with gusd with the zoom yesterday
we're excited about launching the event
in Glendale the biggest concern right
now is every major Hotel will announce
what these places are and we'll give the
names out to people no has said no every
Armenian Hall in Glendale has said come
and do the event on what's going on with
LAUSD and gust with what kind of content
they're trying to put into schools and
we will announce the date here very soon
first we're going to announce that
underground because we want the right
people to show up then I'll announce it
publicly and everyone's worried about
you know rioting protesting all this
other stuff here's the point while this
movie comes out and it's doing so well
can you show up how Rolling Stone
responded to
I send you those different screenshots
when I airdropped it to you what Rolling
Stone said about cuties versus this what
different platforms said about cuties
versus this and by the way while you're
looking for that maybe show the clip of
the video of what the CNN person said
about this if you know which one I'm
talking about where the CNN is asking
the question so what do you think about
this movie you know there's a lot of
people that are saying that there's some
right-wing Q Anon you know what do you
think about this and this guest you
should see what this gets right there if
you can make that bigger you should see
what this guest says about this movie
familiar with him watch his goal we play
this of course watch this
and you seem pretty familiar with him
because he doesn't really hide his
association with this real wild plot
that that involves you know drinking the
blood of children and things like that
no he doesn't hide it at all and you
have a lot of people who are in this
world of Q Anon who say oh they don't
know what that is they've never heard of
it they're just asking questions with
somebody like Jim Caviezel he is openly
embracing it he's openly using its catch
phrases and its Concepts he's speaking
at Q Anon conventions and this film is
being marketed to either specific Q Anon
Believers or to people who believe all
of the same tenets as Q Anon but claim
they don't know what it is
and the sound of Freedom does focus on a
real issue of sex trafficking but that
theme it's sort of like that kernel of
truth that feeds the Q Anon conspiracy
theory tell us how those two things work
together
sure and the most durable and the most
believable conspiracy theories are not
entirely false there's something in them
that is true and the rest of it is false
but the Believers point to the one true
thing and they say oh you don't believe
that this particular thing is true in
terms of child trafficking we know
trafficking is real we know it has real
victims no one is denying that but these
films are created out of moral panics
they're created out of bogus statistics
they're created out of fear and with
something like sound of Freedom it
specifically is looking at keyword on
concepts of these child trafficking
rings that are run by the high-level
Elites and only people like Tim Ballard
and only people like Jim Caviezel and by
extension only people like the ticket
buyer can help bring these trafficking
Rings down so there's a very
participatory element you're not just
going to see a movie you're just killing
two hours on a hot day you are helping
bring down these these pedophile rings
and save children now it's not true but
it's a very comforting and it's a very
warm feeling you know why you have to
trust this guy Pat he has books behind
them anyway that sits with books smart
but but notice it if you work out you're
a white ring you're you're a white
supremacist whatever if you're by the
way this movie was docked like they
actually have footage of everything that
happened uh Tim Ballard because it
happened did you see the movie I saw
them oh you saw it well I saw the movie
and uh I was telling Pat some some crazy
moments or what they actually had
footage undercover footage or
surveillance footage of people in third
world countries and stuff going up to
people like a kid wanders in the street
they grab them in a van and they're gone
it's not a conspiracy theorist and then
it begs the question when people are
like why does one side uh want uh open
borders and why is it if you think about
it pat there's an effect 350
000 unaccompanied miners come across the
border since 2021 till right now 85 000
of them have gone missing and then that
begs the question why is one side just
like no the board is secure my York is
that little rat no the board is open
that is just an end inventory of just
human beings coming in and it's like for
them to say that it's Q Anon and it's
fake it's like they're almost they don't
want people messing with their influx of
children it's a huge problem and yes
they made money off this movie but now
look how many people are talking about
sex trafficking and these and these kids
and at least somebody now is opening
their mouth and by the way this movie
was made five years ago I don't know if
you guys yeah this movie's old now it's
which movie that sounds Freedom yeah
nobody wanted to put on go ahead lord
well it was it was made by Fox before
the Disney acquisition so then Disney
they essentially didn't release it they
didn't want to release it they sold it
to this other studio and the studio
actually had to crowdfund to get a
theatrical release so that's kind of
what's ironic about the fact that it did
beat Indiana Jones at least for one
weekend is that this could have been
money going to Disney but it's also kind
of suspicious why didn't Disney want to
release this movie was it not in line
with their their branding and by the way
isn't Disney a kids channel isn't it
like about kids and protecting kids so
why wouldn't you want to protect kids
worldwide is that kind of weird perhaps
they don't really want it and isn't a
shock and learn that they're
they're in all this stuff
this stuff like
for a fact that this happened he was
murdered don't believe the hype he was
suicide himself that's all [__] uh
CNN producers didn't caught left and
right for for pedophilia the the numbers
are staggering it's in the news it's not
reported a lot and just just perverted
people have to catch a predator do you
guys know that show yes we had Chris
Hanson on here guess what that show
couldn't be can run every single day for
forever because there's an imp there's
there's no shortage of pedophiles the
only reason that shows stop is because
one of these idiot demons ran in the
house and killed himself and that's
what's frustrating about that CNN guy
he's acting like moral outrage over this
is bad or unwarranted she's asking oh
it's to spread fear yeah you should be
afraid for your children you should be
actively trying to prevent this why is
more outrage bad when this is something
that's objectively evil this is an area
to be intolerant in like zero tolerance
for this by the way watch this so
rolling stone look look how different
the the titles are sound of freedom is a
superhero movie for dads with brain
worms the Q Anon thing the Thriller
about child trafficking is designed to
appeal the conscience of a conspiracy
adult Boomer okay pretty wild now let's
go to the next one watch this next one
here the guardian cuties review
Netflix's controversial child
exploitation film is bold flawed and
misunderstood
misunderstood okay so here's the next
one cuties review a coming-of-age movie
Caught in the culture wars thanks to a
major marketing mistake this
award-winning French movie has been
accused of sexualizing girls it's
actually a sensitive portrait of growing
pains that deserve to be seen oh you are
the enemy kidding go to the next one
okay the human traffic film sound of
Freedom trash by liberal Outlets as Q
Anon uh adjacent so when you when you
see this then go to the article about
post-millennial
that talks about if you can pull this up
that talks about uh Rolling Stone
editor-in-chief Spike reporting on
friend getting arrested for child porn
this was a story from March of uh 21st
of this year if you want to go to page
24 uh if you can pull that up that
picture right there good that's the
article right there I'll read it to you
so Rolling Stone Editor in Chief Noah uh
shacked men removed references to child
pornography charges from a story about
ABC's producer James Gordon Meek who was
later charged with possessing child
pornography shackman who was friendly
with Meek edited the piece and Earth
journalist Tatiana Siegel not to include
the words child pornography in the story
claiming that the FBI's interest in Meek
was unrelated to National Security or
journalism shacklin's decision to edit
the story and remove key information
about the child pornography pornography
investigation race concerns within
Rolling Stone Siegel was reportedly not
aware of the changes until the article
was published and was angered by what
she saw as interference shackmans
Justified is that it's by stating that
Siegel had not adequately verified her
sources when you read this stuff this is
what we ought to be intolerant towards
right and there I don't know if you guys
are familiar with the meme from Oren
McIntyre uh don't make me tap the sign
and it's just this post that says it's
not that complicated they just wanted
little kids and I think we all have a
normalcy bias where we would like to
think this is just not that common
shadowy it doesn't really affect our
lives but this is like you said it's
everywhere it's very common it's too
common and there are a lot of policies
that we could actively change that would
prevent this things like closing the
Border because there is a huge porous I
mean I remember uh what is it Melania
Trump she got made fun of when she was
talking about the coyotes uh on that
recorded tape and how that was an issue
I mean the left-wing media is like what
is she things happening blah blah blah
like you don't have to say anything
about it but the fact that you're even
going out of your way to discredit this
problem it's very suspicious that's all
it's very they're protecting they're
protecting their own like that's that's
that's how the left operates for that
imagine that guy's name was Miles Clee
the Rolling Stone guy who locked down
his Twitter account like a [__] because
every he couldn't take the Flack of like
you mean to tell me girls twerking is a
coming of age in a culture like what the
hell would you qualify that as whole
tendency for him too
okay yeah Rob I just sent you something
on how grooming Works check this out if
you can play with show this Meme here
Rob I just text you and I put it on your
computer so the question then becomes a
follow-up right we got five more minutes
here before we wrap up I wish we had
more time and we got like so many
freaking stories to go through but I got
11 o'clock Max seven call so if you can
pull this up does this work is this an
effective strategy well here we go let
me just show you this picture here from
a kid in 2015 to 2022 that's the kid on
the left now grown man on the Right
Bingo grooming works it's actually very
uh effective strategy and yes you can
convert do to your environment do I did
a video on um the the history of lgbtq
the dark exposed the dark history and I
got a lot of messages about a piece of
powder I don't know if you should upload
this I don't know if you haven't seen
that clip I suggest you go watch it
because it tells you
how it got started and and how was
categorized just in 1973 50 years ago
and what's been happening with this this
level of growth and conversion of people
by Generations you know how they say the
older generation doesn't give a [__]
like the older generation doesn't give a
[__] what you think about them like dude
if they're going to smoke weed guess
what who the hell are you I'm 75 years
I'm gonna show what you think about me
who cares more the younger generation or
the older generation about what other
people think younger the younger the
older generation doesn't give a [__] do
you know traditionalist what percentage
of traditionalists this is a generation
before Boomers you know what Precision
of traditionals are gay 1.7 percent do
you know what percentage of gen Z is
getting 25 19.7 wow so the generation
that cares more about what people think
you haven't seen this that's cool this
up right I saw the Bill Maher the
generation the generation that doesn't
give a [__] about what you and I think
only 1.7 percent of them are gay the
generation that gives a [__] about what
everybody thinks 20 is gay oh it's not
big because of environment they're born
this way oh yeah yeah you're you're
totally right there's still 20. you
haven't seen this I don't know if you in
your video talk about the twin studies
that they've done so they uh they do
studies or they did some studies on
identical twins so if if sexuality is
inherent you're born with it it's in
your DNA you would expect that 100 of
identical twins would share a sexuality
I both gave both straight what have you
but what they've actually found is that
that is not the case there are many many
examples of identical twins that have
different sexualities indicating that
for at least some people yeah there
there is a a nurture aspect of it and
what's really interesting is that women
more so than men were likely to have a
different sexual identity than their
identical twins so that means that
women's sexuality or whatever you might
call it is even more fluid than that of
men's and when we see the explosion LGBT
identities guess what it's mainly in
young teen girls who are saying they're
bisexual they're pansexual they're
gender fluid or whatever it is but by
the way this is this is the poll from
2021 the one I quoted was from 2023 but
even better look at this gen Z 20.8
percent identifies lgbtq look at
traditionalists before 1946.8 the 0.8
doesn't give a [__] about what we think
less than one percent of them are gay
okay the Gen Z that cares about what
everybody thinks about them one out of
five well I think there's a recent
report that says for Brown University I
want to say I don't know if it's that
specifically but 40 of students identify
as LGBT I wonder why last thing last
thing to do here with five minutes left
guys is Jamie Diamond Jamie Diamond gave
a speech if he can pull that up Rob if
you have it Jamie Diamond gives a speech
uh he's at a conference I don't know
where he's at and they ask him about
America he gives the speech I retweeted
this and I said anybody that's willing
to sell America like this guys I wish
there was more the reason why I like
seeing I respect anybody who runs
whatever country they run they should be
a nationalist of their country being
proud when Putin sells uh Russia and his
approval rating is the highest in the
world that thinks that 80 or something
when he sells Russia and we bash America
and the approval rating of ours is low
well our history we have a bad history
we're this we're that look at what Jimmy
Diamond says here go for it
the other way around America has the
best hand ever dealt of any country on
this planet today ever
okay and Americans don't fully
appreciate what I'm about to say we have
peaceful wonderful Neighbors in Canada
and Mexico
we've got the biggest military barriers
ever built called the Atlantic and the
Pacific
we have all the food water and energy we
will ever need
okay we have the best military on the
planet and we will for as long as we
have the best economy and if you're a
liberal listen closely to me in that one
okay because the Chinese would love to
have our economy we have the best
universities on the planet they're great
ones elsewhere but these are the best we
still educate uh you know most of most
of the kids who start businesses around
the world we have a rule of law which is
exceptional if you don't believe me and
we talk about Britain Brazil Russia and
the Venezuela Argentina uh China India
believe me it's not quite there we have
a magnificent work ethic we have
Innovation from the core of our bones
you can ask anyone in this room what can
you do to be more productive ask your
assistance Factory floors we do it it's
not just the Steve Jobs it's the broad
death where the wise and deepest
financial markets the world's ever seen
okay and if you I just made a list of
these things and maybe I missed
something go it's extraordinary
it's extraordinary it is America yes we
have problems
by the way do you know when this speech
was from no take a guess
I don't care if it's 10 years ago a
month ago or a day that's my point I
don't care no that's great it's Timeless
yeah that's my point the speech was in
2016. America think about where we've
come
in the last eight years seven years
since this speech it's as it's as
relevant and as poignant as ever and
he's being called upon by what Bill
Ackman these days left and right bro you
gotta run now's your chance not your
chance you know he's 67 years old worth
almost two billion dollars by the way
forget about the fact that he's 67 or
two billion dollars you know he's got a
900 million dollar art collection and a
secret building he's built but have you
seen this thing pull up Jamie diamonds
900 million dollars let me tell you more
about this guy do you know he was an
assistant a personal assistant to Sandy
wow you're not what company in 1982
American Express that's where this guy
got started as an assistant to Sandy
well and more importantly today
do you know how much money every day
circulates with Chase 10 trillion
dollars a day in 170 countries in 120
different currencies that's this guy one
of his famous quotes he said
uh if you don't bring up the problem to
me it's your problem
if you bring up the problem to me it's
our problem trust me you want to bring
me the problem okay I'm prefacing what
he said but this but again yes the
Epstein stuff what happened in 2013 when
they stopped doing business with Epstein
and they said look we don't want you to
be here they cancel an account even
though he was with them for 30 years and
they say oh we never communicated with
them there was like 1200 email exchanges
with one of the guys Staley that was
working there there is that side of it
but the point here is we need more
people in America to sell America 100 I
don't give your military I don't care if
you're a capitalist I don't care if
you're a politician I don't care if
you're in a media space sell America we
have such a great argument to keep
selling America I'll give you the final
thoughts here before we wrap up well
this is going to be a very nerdy final
thought but I'm not sure if you're
familiar with the work of Charles Murray
uh the bell curve gets a bad rap but he
talks about how America is one of the
few countries where it's actually better
to be born smart than it is to be born
rich just because you have the idea of
self-determination it's one of the few
places where you can work hard and get
what you are worth which is not the case
for the vast majority of countries out
there and it's something that we take
for granted that was basically how he
ended his speech I know you got to run
odds he actually runs and what party he
would run give me five percent here's
his answer when they ask him if he's a
Republican or Democrat he said my heart
in my heart I'm a democrat in my brain
I'm a republican he's always kind of by
the way that's kind of like the script
on you to see over big bang or Goldman
Sachs you have to say that yeah but it's
less than five percent I think what is
going to happen is the sooner they get
rid of Biden the sooner people are going
to get in does he have a shot Jamie
can't speak he can sell his charismatic
he's he's talked to everybody he knows
Finance he knows politics he's been
around he's done the power plays the
guy's a genius the guy you know he's got
a philosophy that he follows called The
Fortress philosophy and you know what
his philosophy is have a ton of cash he
had a ton of cash when they bought it
it's a very good philosophy to have yeah
so I think five percent chance but it
has a lot to do with what happens here
soon the sooner they fire Biden the
sooner he can get in it all depends on
how quickly they do that here's what I
do want to do if you guys enjoyed Lauren
today do me a favor please go to our
YouTube channel below if you can put the
link there go subscribe to her Channel
you can see your content there uh let's
also put all the social so they can get
her as well you can this is just one
time you had a chance to hear out on our
podcast if you've not been introduced to
us she's a rock star she puts out great
content and she's provocative she she
challenges she pushes the envelope and
she has her own voice and it's great to
have you on and we appreciate you for
coming out this was fantastic uh and
hopefully we'll do it again in the
future in the next 18 months while this
crazy election Cycle's taking place yeah
I'd love to and again thank you so much
for the opportunity it's been a good
time fantastic and we're back Thursday
again who are we with on Thursday
Charlie Kirk from turning Channel
fantastic so gang we'll see you guys on
Thursday take care everybody bye bye